all the law that all the lunacy begins
tonight on The Bachelorette that's what
I'm most excited I cannot wait for this
honestly I can't wait Rachel Lindsay is
gonna need her 31 suitors and we found
the secrets behind those epic
introductions this right here wife
material I'm looking for husband
material
well producers started casting Rachel's
husband material months before she was
even picked to be the Bachelorette and
once they find a guy they like there's
background checks
there's psychological background
profiling there's blood tests to make
sure that everybody's clean I'm sure
there are things that could slip through
the cracks but anyway we're not the feds
producers also been through this a
little bit this season Jonathan's job
title is tickle monster but he's
actually a doctor chris says it's to
make contestant more memorable to
viewers we figure when we when we have
some fun with these labels it's it's not
necessarily what they are it's kind of
who they are producers also help
mastermind those crazy first
introductions tonight expect a marching
band and plenty of creative costume
Rachel's gown tonight is by Randy rom
and a similar one will cost you around
$7,000 but she didn't have to buy it she
gets a stylist and a glam team but the
contestants don't get a wardrobe and
producers have a reason for that - what
do you choose to wear on this date
because that says a lot about you and so
if we dress everybody and make everybody
look perfect that's not who you are and
what about the show's most coveted
accessories this finger is ready Rachel
already revealed she gets engaged this
season but what will happen to that
bling if it doesn't work out like so
many other bachelor couples I think
there's probably just a vault or a
bucket and there's green cuz it doesn't
work out occasionally
[Music]